[Music]
yes currently Well, we are a
little sad about the situation that is
occurring in this place, a
cemetery that has been in operation for more than 80 years
and against
nature we cannot fight, we
cannot do anything
[Music]
well  have a safe place because here
we are risking that right now the
winter the sea will continue running and we don't
know what will happen
later right Because we are still
waiting for the winter we are not in
winter and look how the sea is now
right
[Music  ]
Look how it looks here Here they had to
dig
and take out,
look and take out
the pantheons inside of the sand and take out their dead,
look Yes, the construction is already in process right now,
where they are going to be
buried, they are going
to be already  our points have been added
So my grandmother, my grandmother's mother
and
a little cousin who also died many years ago
and well we can see here that it is
where they already moved where
the pantheons of our relatives are going to be placed and
we can see there the other people
are also  cleaning there because
all this really was an emergency, look